the interesting thing that I think I
enjoy about podcasts and a lot of
audiences do as well is that unscripted
nature I was interviewed by a Wall
Street journalist last week I asked him
what he liked about podcasts because he
listened to them a lot and he said I
really like to see where they're going
and I thought yeah that's exactly it
because in a Legacy Media interview
everything is scripted and you're never
talking to a person you're talking to
the corporation essentially and I'm not
being cynical about that but now you can
sit down with someone and you can risk
exploration that's what Joe Rogan has
been doing so well for so many years you
can have two people having a genuine
discussion about a complex issue so they
can model high quality dialectical
thinking and pull people Along on an
exploratory journey and make it
permanent and that's completely
revolutionary and the possibilities are
Limitless the next thing is you can take
those conversations and you can chop
them up into 30 second pieces of each of
those confined A specialized home that
can attract millions of views